[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installments of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the main character of the
fantastic beasts franchise
newt scamander and the school that we
all know and love
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry we're first introduced to newt
scamander in the new fantastic beasts
films
but he's one of the main characters
though much of fantastic beasts
takes place in the us so far newt is
actually originally from the uk
and this of course means that he
attended hogwarts in his later years
newt became a famed magic zoologist and
authored fantastic beasts
and where to find them a book which
outlines the study of magical creatures
i have visited lairs
burrows and nests across five continents
observed the curious habits of magical
beasts in a hundred countries
witnessed their powers gained their
trust and on occasion
beaten them off with my traveling kettle
in the films we see newt interact with a
much younger albus dumbledore
who at the time is only a professor at
hogwarts and not yet headmaster
when nude visits the school he's already
man but it's clear that he's quite
familiar with hogwarts
we're even shown a flashback of him as a
young boy attending the school
but one thing that's fairly unclear is
whether or not newt actually properly
graduated from the school
as we know that he was subject to an
expulsion at one point
in the school year of 1913 newt's love
interest
lethal lestrange had an experiment with
a javi go awry
jarvis are magical creatures resembling
massively overgrown ferrets
and it has been expressed the liters
experiment but the life of another
student in danger
her little experiments also violated
laws pertaining to the possession of the
creature
and the combination of the two penalties
would have resulted in
her expulsion however newt who didn't
want to see her punished
took the blame for what lita had done
securing his expulsion from the school
what this should tell us is that newt
never graduated from hogwarts
however in the about the author section
of fantastic beasts
and where to find them newt's book there
is an excerpt which suggests that newt
did end up graduating upon graduation
from hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
mr scamander joined the ministry of
magic in the department for the
regulation
the control of magical creatures so what
does this mean
this seems to suggest that he graduated
and it's only further complicated by a
tweet from rowling that sort of suggests
the opposite once again
dumbledore was a young teacher at the
time newt was expelled he wasn't able to
revoke expulsions
so did he graduate or not this is all
very confusing
fortunately there is a tie-in book which
examines the events
of fantastic beasts a little bit further
in the case of beasts
explore the film wizardry of fantastic
beasts and where to find them
there is an article directly addressing
the details and outcome of newt's crimes
notes proposed expulsion from hogwarts
school of witchcraft and wizardry
due to the illegal possession of a
magical beast causing endangerment of
human life
and violation of animal welfare laws
101-304
magical beast jarvi level 3 punishment
expulsion from hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
further notes the expulsion was never
enforced
hogwarts professor albus dumbledore
defended newton resulting in his name
being cleared
the ministry of magic animal welfare
department were also informed of the
violation
and required to re-house the magical
creature so what this means is that
though newt was
expelled it was never actually enforced
i'm not sure that expulsion is
expulsion without enforcement but
apparently that's what happened
it looks like dumbledore stepped in to
defend newt which is really no surprise
given that dumbledore was a big newt fan
he even gave newt's book rave reviews
newt's masterpiece had been an approved
textbook at hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
ever since its publication and must take
a substantial amount of credit
for our students consistently high
results in care of magical creatures
examinations
based on all of this i think that it's a
fair assumption to say
that newt did end up graduating from the
school and was certainly allowed to keep
his wand
what do you guys think did newt graduate
is this all a bit messy to you as well
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
it is the quality of one's convictions
that determine success
not the number of followers
you